los
resultados el chavismo afianza su poder
en venezuela el presidente nicolás
maduro celebró los resultados de las
elecciones regionales del domingo en las
que se eligieron más de 3000 gobernantes
alcaldías y ayuntamientos de las 24
entidades federales
del país el gran polo patriótico las
fuerzas revolucionarios hemos ganado 21
e incluyendo la capital de la república
bolivariana de venezuela caracas de 24
buen triunfo por su parte los rivales
del partido socialista unido de
venezuela ganaron solamente en los
estados de cojedes zulia y nueva esparta
para el opositor juan guaidó estos
comicios mostraron apatía por parte de
los ciudadanos con un abstencionismo de
casi el 60 por ciento
venezuela
con un régimen y killing un régimen
ilegítimo no solamente sino también en
desempeño señalado por delitos de lesa
humanidad ingreso en amanece un 94 por
ciento de pureza pero algunos críticos
aseguran que la falta de unión entre
opositores y la carencia de mensajes
claros motivaron el ausentismo además en
caracas muchos dudan de la transparencia
del reciente proceso y realmente yo
pienso que eso fue trampa nuevamente o
sea no hay otra y yo veo difícil que
salgamos de esto sino si nosotros los
venezolanos pues no tomamos otra acción
pues porque estoy es a todo el mundo en
todos lados aquí por ejemplo venezuela
quejándose de que no hay no hay ya no
hay agua la gasolina pero entonces en
este momento ve que todo el que apoyan
al gobierno los resultados de las
regionales son un nuevo revés para la
oposición luego de boicotear las
elecciones presidenciales en 2018 y las
elecciones al congreso en 2020